and we actually have some new merch this
is new merch stuff from bgty some
beautiful colorways there for the summer
time
things that uh are good for men and
women
both uh gender
and
um and also we have the new Rat King
these new Rat King summer tees and
shorts and you can check all those out
only at theovanstore.com
um
we know there's some other stores out
there but those aren't ours and uh I
love this shirt my sister loves this
shirt and uh thank you guys for the
support
I'm here today at the Wynn Casino uh in
the green room we just got off the stage
and so grateful to be here had a
wonderful show on Sunday night
uh today's guest is an actor a comedian
he's a Creator and a star of the hit
show Workaholics and he has a new movie
on Netflix that drops it's it's I think
it's on right now
um today's guest is Mr Adam
divine
Vine
[Music]
I'll sit and tell you my story
foreign
[Applause]
Nashville in here huh that's what
friends are for God
friends sparkling
brought to you by Celsius
I'll have some
crack One open zip
dude remember they used to have the uh
that commercial about the mustard in the
car or whatever like the grapple Pawn
Yeah remember that yeah I do and
everybody yeah was like it was so yeah
and every dad and uncle would be like uh
past the gray Poupon and you're like
[__] we don't have that we just got
that that yellow stuff yeah if we don't
have that because you're a construction
worker yeah Dad you work for the
railroad we don't have gray Poupon here
yeah dude that doesn't go on our on our
brought bursts yeah we had this guy he
this guy my mom dated used to be like
past that yellow ketchup he would say
yellow ketchup yeah that's what he used
to call it cool man I think he was in
like a war or something he had some like
he might have had like some uh he was in
like Iwo Jima or something but let me
see this there it is right there that's
the guy yeah that's the guy dude well it
looks like there was a lot of different
guys over the years they didn't stick
they didn't stick with the
the one spokesman yeah that was this was
like and this was for a lot of this was
the richest guy we'd ever seen when they
had this we were like no well also this
is still the richest guy I've ever seen
who eats with a full-on TV tray in the
in their back of their car that's pretty
awesome that's sick
that's sick dude that's pretty that's
Rolls-Royce I every time I'm like I
don't really want like a real fancy car
because I don't I don't give a [__] you
know yeah but then like I I'll see a
Rolls Royce I'll see like DJ Khaled in a
Rolls-Royce or something I'm like oh
that looks pretty cool though there's
like a there's like
feet warmers and uh like just the back
part as it can be a convertible which is
kind of sick really I've never seen that
oh yeah yeah DJ Khaled I haven't seen
that yeah
yeah I think um yeah when I see like a
superf I don't know I don't like I think
the fancier you get the fancier you can
get used to and that to me always seems
like super spooky yeah because then all
of a sudden you know yeah look at that
look at back convertible that's sick
that is kind of neat that's so cool but
that's like a driver you don't deserve
to be in a convertible but then also
like then you have to have a driver all
the time like if you're like quickly you
just want to go smash some Carl's Jr or
something and then you gotta like call
in the driver yeah that's a lot yeah
that's true that's too much and people
don't realize this somebody took me one
time on a ride in a um
Rolled Royce or whatever and they said
uh we had to park so far away because
they didn't want anybody dinging the
doors or anything so we had to find a
spot like in a lot that was like you
know it was a half mile away from from
the city from the city yeah you gotta
then get a car to get into the city dude
you know I took it back I don't I don't
need a Rolls yeah we don't need that
dude what do you drive you're like a
Rolls-Royce
yeah I want to get in the backseat but
someone needs to drive the damn thing no
I'm I got a
I bought a Camaro Super Sport
convertible 2011 like right when
Workaholics came out I'm like give me
some of this good vroom vroom and then
um and then I never bought a new car I
just have that car still it's like over
12 13 years old now 10 12 12. yeah but
if you ever leave your family I think
that's one thing you have to leave your
family in that well the Camaro Super
Sport is the car you leave families in
yeah you do not you don't have a family
if you have it if you have that car if
you have that car you're you're going to
leave your wife yeah that's the car
that's like hey this car it even has a
goodbye misses button on it yeah yes and
you're leaving with like the Applebee's
waitress yeah yeah that's who that's who
you're rooming off with yeah you're
listening to the Joe Dirt soundtrack
which people don't even know they had
that yeah I'll do that I bet it rips
dude I bet it freaking red how to be
good man
yeah I uh
I I'm doing uh my new movie uh The
Outlaws yeah July 7th July 7th it's a
happy Madison movies so congratulations
thanks dude it's the uh it was the sort
of dream gig is to work with them
because you know like you just said uh
Joe Dirt oh yeah like so many goddamn
classic movies so
yeah me and Spade just wrote a movie
together actually oh [__] and um
Riff Raff involved no
um dude riffraff hit me up and said he's
involved really I'm almost positive he
said I'm gonna have to go back and look
but Riff Raff is not involved
look blessings giraffe baby I think if I
were coming out with like a [__]
never-ending bubble gum or something
yeah you know what I'm saying yeah or if
I were coming out with like a uh
you know like a shoe that made you jump
so high that all the [__] wanted you
yeah yes jump like Raph yeah I mean like
raphaire yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
like you're literally Jude what about
driffraff who would that if they had an
animal called The girifraf Joe riffraff
yeah I thought you were saying like
driffraff like like Tokyo Drift that
drift yeah good that's a good movie yeah
or is that a cool go-kart track that he
starts drift somebody already did it oh
dude that's that's what sucks about the
internet is you you have a great idea
and then obviously some 13 year olds in
Michigan beat you to it yeah you know
yeah yeah that's the one downside of the
internet yeah because it used to be if
you had a good idea in a moment you
could just say it was your good idea
dude I was convinced that I came up with
the The Rocketeer
Remember The Rocketeer the guys with the
pack I was convinced that I had that
idea first and then when it came out I
was like how did they know how did they
steal my idea it was in my journal uh
I'm in like third grade or however old I
was convinced how'd they get in there
how'd they steal it who did it who did
it yes somebody they had a rumor going
around our area that pillows were taking
people's ideas and sent them to the
government who was pillows all the
pillows big pillow like sleeping pillow
yeah it was like big pillow was like
[__] everybody and so people weren't
using pillows I remember for almost
eight months
and people were pissed yeah like we
ain't [__] oh yeah that dream uh so
then you're just smashing blankets
together trying to form a pillow you
could yeah yeah you're just sleeping on
beds and marshmallows yeah sleeping on
your chubbiest Brothers midsection yeah
[__] you table
um but the Outlaws no no first of all
congrats on being a movie star yeah dude
how weird is that it's very interesting
well it's just when we knew each other
way back in the day you didn't I didn't
know this was this is the the biggest
podcaster in the game and you didn't
look at me going like this guy's a movie
star that's not what we thought no I
thought he was a guy in a hallway yeah
yeah
there's a fellow white kid doing comedy
yeah here's another one of these chuckle
homes yeah there's another chuckle honky
that classic term
um and look whoever if someone else
probably made that term if Mr if you
bring it up right now there's some yeah
there's a chuckle honky uh
and it's just our photos on a giraffe
weirdly don't know why but some other
kid Drew Us in his journal uh-huh some
third grader in Minnesota put us in his
journal and it's oh it's actually our
pictures like how did it even do that
yeah he wrote pod podcaster underneath
your photo actor underneath mine uh and
the year was 2012 and look at us now wow
but no congratulations well it's
interesting because you you start off
just as a comedian yeah is that I mean
that's
yeah essentially I mean we we knew each
other for since like being in the
hallways of the Improv like and back in
the day uh but was your goal always to
be an actor I don't know if I've I don't
know if you've not talked about this or
not I know you've had Workaholics I know
you've had a string of movies I know all
of this but I'm just wondering where
you're your original idea was because
it's interesting when a comedian goes
they get into movies and they become a
movie star yeah not a lot of people have
that path so it's just different you
know you're a rare person we can talk to
about yeah I think uh yeah it was kind
of always the dream the dream was like
the dream was basically like Sandler's
path path you know like seeing like what
he was able to do do stand up I wanted
to do SNL that that just never came to
be uh and then and then do movies
um yeah essentially I started when I was
a kid I watched a lot of like evening at
The Improv uh remember that a e show
with like Bud Freeman he'd wear his
monocle and then they bring up the the
comics and and I never saw it oh really
oh yeah it was was it that oh God is
that the guy with the uh well bud
Freeman's The Improv owner and he died
he just died yeah not too long ago uh
but he uh yeah so I like loved
by stand up and then you Swatch so much
of it and I'm sure you kind of did the
same thing it wasn't like for me it
wasn't like the the best Comics they
didn't inspire me because I was like I'm
not that smart like I can't figure that
out [__] out Oh you mean like a Louis
ckara Steven Wright or something or like
a Chris Rock or something yeah Chris
Rock you know where you're just like oh
God these guys are geniuses it was like
the guys I saw on TV that like weren't
that good and I was like well I could be
that good right I know I could be that
good
if that's what takes that's what it
takes to get on TV I know I could be
that successful I can do that uh yeah
and so and then even at the Improv had
everybody but um oh wow but he was
watching some some of these people and
they were like oh they're not that funny
dude I can be that funny right and then
I uh I got a job at The Improv which I
think is probably around when I met you
and and that was in like 2004. it was
Anthony Clark working there then too or
not do you remember that Anthony Clark
wasn't yeah he was there all the time
but he wasn't working there then no
because I would see oh no he never
worked he never worked there he was just
always he was always there was he there
then that's what I mean yeah no he was
he was drinking at the bar so much that
that we should have paid him uh yes
sorry Anthony I haven't seen Anthony
Clark in years and no one has wow he was
a he was a television star I mean he was
on one of the biggest shows yeah uh yes
dear yes and then uh his other show is
Boston Common oh yeah that deep cut
references I have to get dude I would
love to sit and talk with Anthony Clark
I bet he would be really interesting oh
yeah wow I haven't seen him in years
anyway sorry I hadn't thought about that
so you worked at The Improv yeah and
then it was like uh it was you crossed
when you got on stage we did a show at
USC together one time I remember yeah
that's right and um that might have been
maybe when Workaholics was out and then
after that came out it was just
you just went into this other world that
a lot of us aren't in
yeah well we got so [__] lucky you
know it was like that's what it is it's
like you just sort of prepare and try to
put yourself in the right place at the
right time and then
and then you get your shot and hopefully
you're able to hit it you know yeah and
we we got so lucky it was funny like
when Workaholics came out because like I
was kind of the kid at The Improv where
I was like working the door and [__] and
then I'd come on stage and like there
wasn't a ton of respect it was like yeah
we know he worked here right uh like
yeah some of you that guy would even be
up there he'd be mid-order he'd be
taking his fries they'd call his name
yeah I remember watching one guy do us
that was I'm with fries
yeah so it wasn't like a uh and then as
soon as soon as the the show came out
where hogs came out then all of a sudden
it was like all the older Comics were
like oh hey what's up man I'm like yeah
[__] you don't know me
oh so now we're friends okay that's a
good point yeah
Hollywood is weird like that man it is
weird there's a certain sometimes
there's a certain like
you want someone needs to have the same
experiences as you and then that can
bring you it can make you feel like you
can talk to somebody or things you're a
little more comfortable yeah there are
weird lessons yeah there's a lot there's
like there's levels to this [__] as Meek
Mill said yeah uh and it's true it's
like you just talk to people that are
like I feel like we are kind of in the
same class within like a few years of
each other kind of know you know and uh
and then there's like kids that are
coming up that you're like oh they're
the class beneath beneath us and and
it's not that they're worse or better
it's it's just that they were a
different they came up at a different
time oh yeah I feel like it's it's like
whoever you were like doing open mics
with or like doing the like first group
of like bringer shows with yeah that's
who you're like hey yeah hey we're gonna
be friends forever because we performed
in a Chinese restaurant you know because
we're performing when there's literally
bowling happening right here like they
were getting heckled by bowling pins uh
so we're always gonna know each other
yeah
yeah there's something kind of uh
there's something
um it's a it's weird that yeah there's
something weird about that when you come
in at the same time who kind of
introduces you to somebody else's
interesting too because it's almost like
uh how you if somebody like you get
co-signed kind of somebody to be you
know because some people it's like
um
you almost some people they get their
lives get so busy it's like it's hard
for them to just be friends with every
single person that comes along too you
know as their career gets busier and
they get more known I know dude like now
I go I'll go into the Improv and [__]
and I like won't know people which is
which is like that sucks because it used
to be like you go to the comedy club and
you know everybody yeah like you know
everybody including like the wait staff
and you just you just know people oh
yeah and then now you're I'm like I go
in there and I'm like
hello yeah I used to be a comedian
back in the day
I would go on this very stage
Ah that's awesome man
um well congrats man congrats on having
it and and a steady career in in movies
too because I know that probably gets
pretty tricky
um I want to I want to think about what
that's like with you and but first I
want to think a little bit about you
know the the new movie because Tom
Segura has his specialist coming out on
the same day yeah I think it's it's the
same day or just about this that's
awesome yeah yeah that's awesome he was
just on his episodes up right now
um yeah he's Tom is so funny uh yeah sir
tell me about Outlaws man let me let me
I want to know a little bit about it
yeah so I mean you're an executive
producer I know that yeah producer on it
I uh the the writers uh Ben I'm always
butcher his last name like I got called
out on my agent was like you're [__]
up this guy's name it's
z-a-z-o-v-e then
great guy awesome writer Ben and Evan
Turner uh they wrote the movie super
funny they brought me this idea like at
like years ago at the tail end of
Workaholics and they're like it's your
it's Meet the Parents meets heat and so
it's if your parents are uh your future
in-laws are International Bank Robbers
okay and they rob the bank that you work
for uh and so yeah so they're there they
are and and we cast Pierce Brosnan
Pierce Bros
oh my god wow man Nina Dobrev plays my
fiancee Michael rookers in it uh you
know Lil Rel oh little rails in there
yeah my boy Blake Anderson has a has a a
small part in it yeah so it's the cast
is sick so they they pitched me this
idea and I'm like just a [__] idiot
dude and I was like that is a brilliant
idea for a movie I want to do this movie
wrote it down in my notebook lost that
notebook immediately forgot all about it
and years later I'm like looking through
an old notebook being like Oh what what
Brilliance did I write
gross hated bad idea stupid yeah recipe
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it just is
apples and it's just saying to eat fruit
uh and then and then it was this idea
and I was like oh [__] that's brilliant
I reached out to the guy those guys I
was like hey I'm sure
John Cena is attached or something you
know someone has already beat me to this
yeah Flavor Flav Flavor Flav is probably
you know that movie star Flavor Flav uh
and then uh they were like no nothing so
wow I uh developed it with them we took
it to Netflix sold it and then brought
on uh Happy Madison from Sailors company
oh that's great yeah now it was cool it
was it's cool when it works out you know
yeah well it's so hard to get a movie
created Created into the Finish Line
especially these days it seems even
harder dude especially comedies nowadays
you have to like mask it this is why
it's a big action comedy because you
really have to go like action action and
then and then it's a comedy but this we
we it's just like it's it's why I was so
happy to work with Sanders company is we
could just go Full Steam on the comedy
as opposed to you know you watch
comedies nowadays and you're like
no this isn't a [__] comedy you're
not where's the jokes like where's the
Bits bad yeah somebody's getting kind of
bad huh yeah it kind of sucks yeah movie
comedy movie.com yeah there's still good
shows and stuff but like yeah movie
comedy uh it's it's hard
but luckily uh I I'm my theory is I
think
I think like Marvel ruined it I feel
like superhero movies kind of ruined
comedies because they people watch you
go to the theater yeah and you expect to
watch something that costs 200 million
dollars to make and comedy movies aren't
that aren't that
so you're like well why would I spend
the same amount of money to go watch a
little comedy in the theater
if I could spend the same amount of
money and go see something that is is
worth 200 million dollars right you know
and then they still make those movies
kind of funny like they're I mean
they're not comedies but there's like
right there's ants they're like oh my
God is that raccoon talking yeah this is
hilarious
which it is but uh but yeah so it's not
it's not like a real comedy and then now
they there used to be something like
every Studio would put out several
comedies every every year and there was
like 45 or 46 comedies in the theaters
every year so about every week or every
other week or so there's a new comedy in
the theaters and uh and then now last
year there was like six or seven
crazy it's crazy and people need and the
crazy thing is is this feels like people
need comedy more than ever yeah I feel
like they want it I feel yeah so that's
what this movie was it was like and
there's no like hidden message I feel
like nowadays
people like you get to the end of what
you think is a comedy and you're like is
that about global warming yeah yeah
you're like is this is just like some
deep hidden message that I'm supposed to
I'm supposed to recycle more or like you
know yeah there has to be something else
right oh the Moon is trans is that what
yeah is that the surprising yeah okay I
guess we do have to think about that
don't we
yeah I agree there's there's a lot of
what was that was a great and that's
what your David Spade and your movie is
about yeah trans Moon yeah
you guys are just the people to to
spread that message oh it's about
Transportation it's about a lot of
vehicles admitting who they really are
the cars wanting to be motorcycles
motorcycles wishing they were scooters
yeah it's just it's where things are man
oh dude there's a riveting scene where a
short bus uh admits that he's a
skateboard yeah
and it's yeah it's powerful whoa
but the great thing is I feel like you
could walk into a place and pitch that
and then yeah and they wouldn't laugh
you out of the room they'd be like
okay well that's the thing you know
because I like my job now is kind of
well obviously acting and that kind of
stuff but then like I'm pitching a lot
so I'll like pitch movies uh and every
executive is like yeah but why should we
make this movie now and you're like
because it's funny yeah because it's
funny [__] what do you mean like
whatever happened to just like we want
to make people laugh like it doesn't
need to be right yeah right there it
doesn't need to attach itself to some
like hook in the world right now it
doesn't I mean if it does and that's the
movie then sure right but it doesn't
always have to it could just be like
whatever happened to just it's funny for
funny sake I know I feel like super bad
was one of the last movies that they
kind of had like that in some ways like
that was really just super fun it like I
mean there's been a lot of other funny
movies I'm not saying that
um yeah but I get what you're saying it
was like The Hangover super bad it was
like that was sort of the last gasp of
like for no reason at all like this is
just [__] funny because it's funny
you know you ever been injured had
something fall along here hit you
you working at the lumber yard and dang
and I ate by seven tumbles on you
turned your neck into a dang Jenga game
Morgan and Morgan
that's right if you're ever injured you
can check out Morgan and Morgan
America's largest injury Law Firm
they have over 100 offices Nationwide
and more than 800 lawyers with over 15
billion dollars recovered for clients
Morgan and Morgan has a proven track
record of fighting to get you full and
fair compensation
that's right submitting a claim to
Morgan and Morgan is easy
it's easy as dang looking at your feet
submitting our claim to Morgan and
Morgan is as easy as picking out a shirt
for a toddler put him in it boy put that
little toddler in that little in that
little camisa that means shirt
if you're ever injured you can check out
Morgan and Morgan their fee is free
unless they win for more information go
to forthepeople.com
slash this past weekend
that's f-o-r-t-h-e
-p-e-o-p-l-e.com slash this past weekend
or dial pound law pound 529 from your
cell phone that's for the people.com
this past weekend or dial pound law
pound 529 from your cell this is a paid
advertisement
but that's uh did you feel good about it
was it exciting so this is it's like
there's gone there's weapons in it
people are so there's also there's like
uh like what's the premise of the film
again oh sir so uh sure so my me and
Nina's character were about to get
married I've never met their her parents
my future in-laws they come in the week
before the wedding they've I've never
even seen photos of these people they're
like ghosts and they're just the coolest
[__] it's Pierce Brosnan Ellen
Barkin and they take me out on like
night on the town we go skydiving I get
a tattoo I get uh like we get I get
blackout drunk with them and I'm like
the straight laced Banker so this is out
of the uh out of the norm for me and I
go to the bank the next day and I'm
talking to Lil Rel who I who is a
security guard and I'm like dude last
night was incredible I just need a nice
chill day at work uh you know but my
in-laws are awesome and then click click
there there's a gun in my head two
people are robbing my bank and and they
have masks on and they say something
that leads me to believe that they're my
in-laws yeah wow yeah dude and then they
end up owing someone money
uh because they like bailed with the
money last time the person who cleans
their money like uh like in heat the
person who cleans their money they stole
that money from them and so they oh they
that woman kidnaps my fiance and is like
if you don't give me five million
dollars within the end of the week I'm
gonna kill your daughter and we have to
go rob a series of banks to get uh my
fiance back
yeah dang yeah it's fun yeah it seems
fun yeah it's really fun how long did it
take to shoot something like that I had
like you know two two months or
something were you guys able to shoot in
California no dude you don't shoot
things in California anymore yeah uh
unless there's drugs in the Park oh man
yeah
uh yeah we shot it in Atlanta oh nice
yeah I like Atlanta it was fun yeah
Atlanta's cool man I mean it's
definitely it's it's it's grown so much
in the past 20 years that city
um that's amazing bro congratulations so
this is your first movie your executive
producing too
no so I produced uh game over man which
is the movie I did with the Workaholics
guys and that was uh an action another
action comedy on Netflix but that one
was like this movie is I feel more
accessible like I feel like parents
would want to watch this movie game over
man like there's multiple dicks that are
cut off yeah uh I show my dick and my
butthole in the movie oh wow yeah dude
you gotta you gotta check that out and
uh you you know should check it out and
yeah so a very very funny movie but I
feel like this is a little more uh
accessible to everyone I haven't I
haven't seen this I can't believe I
didn't even know about this yeah dude
yeah it's so hard to know about things
these days do you feel like that too
yeah there's so much happening yeah I
feel like it's uh there's just too much
[__] that's out there and we used to and
also our phones are a device that we go
to now for entertainment there used to
be one device really yeah you know it
was your television and then it became
your television and your computer and
that's when streaming really was at an
insane level you know and then now it's
your television your computer and your
phone you know so I feel like it's
yeah and it's also like the algorithm
just kind of pushes things your way and
if for whatever reason yeah it didn't
push it your way then you have no no
clue oh dude I walked into the last
Blockbuster probably one years ago
and I walked in there dude and
it was like
it was on it was unbelievable and this
is what was the most fascinating to me
about it
um
first of all somebody that worked in
there was like where was this they would
look over their glass that you like you
were being an [__] like which is like
how they always said one person always
used to do that and one dude would be
cool like trying to sell you weed or
something you know yeah uh this is in
Bend Oregon it's the last one oh wow so
there it is right there boy and that's
because they don't get internet up there
or they're just really I think just this
lady doesn't want it to shut down
whoever this is in the picture maybe
yeah that's probably her um but it's
crazy I mean you go in and it's you walk
through the aisles and the interesting
part is
how many options there are you don't
realize how many because when we look on
a screen there's like the 10 or 12
options and even if you look around you
can barely find but in the store I mean
suddenly I'm like oh what about this
maybe I hadn't thought about this movie
or I'll pick it up I'm like oh this will
really be great and I realized how much
of our ability to choose for ourselves
without even realizing it disappeared
when it went to uh streaming platforms
yeah it used to be fun and it used to go
just in like the weird artwork you'd be
like let's give this one a try yeah like
that that person showing like half of a
nipple yeah
oh God I see the other half you got to
see the other half of the nipple do you
think they're going to show the bottom
half of this nipple in the movie God
come on dude yeah I gotta run this and
then the crazy part was if it was a
nipple movie I'd always get raisin Nets
dude because you want to have them
Sticky Fingers well I just want to have
it's almost that fourth dimension of a
nipple they're almost like little
nipples that's true dude that'd be great
for porn movies if they had a box of
like little like you know how they have
those like 4D seats in theaters now like
a 4D porn chair
all this you're just getting hoes spray
weird smells like oh god oh Jesus Too
Close yeah I was like and then it like
bumps you from behind if there's like a
doggy style scene or something like Whoa
this is whoa who's that wait so you're
getting [__] today yeah all right yeah
yeah it depends on what you're watching
yeah it makes sense I think there's
different types of chairs for sure yeah
you might have to invest uh in the right
chair for you you know that's what we're
saying invest in the right porn chair
for you that's all that matters
um but it was pretty fascinating just
how many options there were and I had
never realized how much that went away I
mean because next you know I'm in the
drama section and I'm in the comedy and
then I'm seeing like oh what about this
one dude I never saw this I heard this
came out but it was like I had so much
ability to choose and I it was it was um
anyway it was just kind of fast and it
was fun because then you would watch
those movies yeah you know what I mean
like that's what you were gonna do that
night like Netflix and and you know all
the streaming services yeah I love I
love Netflix yeah they are my good guy
they are my corporate overlords but uh
but we're talking about how the business
has changed and that's okay they're
worried about it too yeah but like you
can just turn off a movie you can watch
15 minutes or something and go affect I
don't want to do this now but like when
you had the movie and that was what
you're doing to watch you would watch a
bad movie and watch the entire thing
because you spent the
eight dollars or whatever it was to rent
the damn movie so you're like well we
have to watch this piece of [__]
we're [__] yeah they're not even
showing the other half of the nipple so
I don't know why we gotta wait to the
very end for the other half nipple to
flop out oh dude dang it was something
about that huh and also I feel like I
feel big candy is probably pretty bummed
because you're no no longer are you
you're not going to the store because
you're gonna go home and watch Netflix
and getting all the Jujubes and Mike and
Ikes and and all the candies hot tamals
hot tamals what are other candies lemon
heads oh Lemonheads oh the ones that had
the little bitty uh white crystals or
the little white stars that's Crystal
Method no cats no cats no caps which is
also a street term for first one
bro anybody that I knew immediately if
somebody got Junior Mints dude that they
were probably into some sick stuff with
children that's what I thought
anybody
that's my favorite candy
it is it is are you serious I love
Junior Minster well dude okay hang on
it's not about whatever I'm not a
[__] kids
I walked into it though I shouldn't have
admitted it but yeah
but uh you put you put uh you get the
popcorn you put the Junior Mints in
there it's a it's a
sweet treat with the salty popcorn
they're not sweet they have [__] mint
they don't do that's a surprise
who rides [__] men from mint is like
spearmint who hides it under a little
layer yeah and it's all gooey yeah now
the gooey part is kind of I do the
texture I don't mind yeah but it's just
some of the others it's the I just don't
like mint I don't want mint to be there
when I'm trying to have something sweet
dang dude I'm sorry it's okay [__] but
it makes me mad I can tell Dude You're
flexing on me it makes me angry yeah I
could tell it makes my [__] teeth
want to climb through my gums oh [__]
[__] that's my bad dude hey Lemonheads
are my favorite all right okay all right
lemon heads were a little crazy too
remember how powerful some candies were
when you were a kid
oh boy
yeah I I used to uh tamales were pretty
powerful when you were young dude when I
was a in high school someone got me as a
gift a 10 pound bucket of Mike and Ikes
I love Mike and eggs I ate the whole 10
pound bucket in a weekend wow and uh I
when I took a [__] it came out at nine
not even joking dude it was translucent
oh I like I I [__] out like a just a
giant Mike and Ike that's unbelievable
that's beautiful yeah dude God so now we
know what clip uh is gonna be used for
to promote this podcast my trip my [__]
was translucent
and I'm I even saying that right
translucent uh I just means clear right
yeah yeah okay all right yeah they
should just say clearly here yeah I was
trying to yeah you're fine I don't know
why they made that word for it yeah
translucent
uh allowing light but not detailed
shapes to pass through that is exactly
what I meant I used it perfectly like I
did well really good I can't do they
have see-through dookie or not
I never even seen that yeah well I have
10 pounds of Mike and eggs
every now and then somebody's got to
test the science out there and I was
willing to be that kid yeah dude there
was some you know what there was just
yeah that was where you would see new
Candy at now candy got it they but there
was only a few kinds of candy back in
the day it was like a 20 cons or
something yeah I remember like payday
was like something my mom would get it
was like the parents candy yeah you
don't you don't [__] pay that no
never but like even like a a thousand
Grand or whatever that was always seemed
like a like an old person's candy yeah
but now I bet payday like I remember my
mom would always [__] up some Almond
Joys oh yeah and I I was like oh [__]
Almond Joy yuck yeah that's old people
[__] and then now like last Halloween I
had a little snack size Almond Joy
they're good
God don't mind if I do oh they're good
man they are good you know I remember
when they came out with nerd ropes and I
was like they they don't change the game
yeah nerd ropes you put it on some
licorice
um
yeah you would see a lot of people doing
unique stuff with them a lot of people
you'd see somebody some their pants like
a thick some thick little fellas pants
had been stitched up with nerd Road like
damn I mean snacking his pants come open
again you always saw that yeah you
always saw that growing up dude in the
90s everyone's stitching their pants up
with some nerd ropes
different times maybe different times
yeah those days truly when like that's
what that was your what you were doing
for the day yeah you were like me and my
homies we're gonna meet at somebody's
front yard we're going to then ride our
bikes to the convenience store get a
video game yep we'll probably play video
games in the store because they always
had like Ninja Turtles or something they
did and then spend a dollar and a
quarter on some on way too much candy
because that's how much candy used to be
able to buy man uh you would have as
much as you [__] could and I hated
Whoppers and then I'll tell you this I
love them Whoppers something just
happened those candies oh yeah the
Whoppers are the the little nuggets
little turd balls it's a little malted
milk in it yeah I like them too God they
were good at first I was like what is it
yeah and then I had some more and I was
like I can handle it yeah you could
I bet you could it was good dude we used
to have so this place boss it was past
video and shrimp right so we'd bike over
there and you get you a little film
and then you get you a little pound of
shrimp with it right wait what there it
was a video and shrimp store yeah off of
Highway 190 in Covington Louisiana you
bike over there that's sick oh it was
pretty I love a good combo store it was
interesting yeah so you get uh the video
and you get your shrimp man and roll out
of there that's sick that was pretty
cool but yeah it was just a different
time you know it was a different time
whenever you go to that uh and this that
was even before the chain Blockbuster I
think they had uh remember because
before that it was like individual yeah
like Ricky's movies yeah we had Main
Street movies yeah yeah that's insane
not even on the Main Street it was like
kind of in a neighborhood you're like
this is that always pissed me off I'm
like this isn't a main street it's a
side street at best
but they and then they had they they all
every movie theater or movie store like
that they had like the curtain where the
the naughty movies were back there yeah
and then you're out you're a little kid
and you'd always just like
try to try to memorize as many of the
covers as you possibly could you just
run in stare at a bunch of covers
yeah you're like all right memorize
memorize uh that's what it looks like
and then your mom's like Adam you're
like what I went in there I thought it
was a bathroom like you think it's the
bathroom every time we come in here
you always think it's the bathroom yeah
and you've peed on the floor and there's
six times yeah you're always going in
there [__] on the floor
I think you're into that scat porno your
little creep
that was wild bro that was fun that was
a good time
um
what else was I just looking at earlier
today that was in the news did you see
what were we talking about earlier today
we're watching this video uh someone
threw their Mom's ashes on stage at a
pink concert
oh yeah
well I mean
did the mom love pink this much that
that's the thing
is this your mom
and how many grams is that
yeah she just started snorting her mom
she's inside of me now and then sings A
Pink song Don't couldn't tell you one
pink song but I'm sure I'm sure she's
great live
what's that song
I don't know yeah but that'd be
something yeah that's about the biggest
thing you can do is probably throw
somebody burnt mom on a stage
well you hope that the mom was like a
die-hard pink fan or else like that's
you're just carrying around your mom all
over to try to like Meet Your Heroes
yeah you're using your mom after the
fact
like if I die and like my future like if
I have a kid and then my kid like uses
it to like go to a JoJo Seawall concert
or some [__] I'd be a little salty you
know like I'm up in heaven I'm like I
don't give a [__] about like Jojo siwa
why are you using me to get close to
Jojo siwa yeah like can I get in this is
my dad you know my dad is and they just
flash a little bag of you yeah yeah
throw throw me in someone's face
no offense to Jojo siwa I'm sure she's
watching oh I'm sure she's doing great
one of my friends used to live next door
to her actually really and she doesn't
she live in like a Cotton Candy Castle
or something I think she does yeah I
think she lives like on one of those on
the like northwest corner of the
Candyland board yeah absolutely
um she's uh Omaha she's an Omaha girl
and so are you I'm on my boy yeah did
you grow up around the uh World Series
at all oh yeah did you go to whatever
yeah oh yeah as a kid uh and then what
we would do is we would go out and like
people are so drunk there that they will
just give alcohol to Children yeah so
you you just stand by the beer tent and
be like come on man and you're like
13 and they're like they're like there
you go I don't care if I go to praise
anyway
this boy in a full-on body cast is
asking for beer he needs he needs one
this way then this dead bird with the
neck Grace it needs a beer totally dude
that's great yeah yeah there's something
about like um there's some there was
some empowering thing probably for an
adult giving liquor to a kid huh yeah I
I feel like I haven't done that enough
as I've been an adult it's probably fun
to see a kid get [__] up is that an
insane thing to say or not no dude it's
for sure fun like it's always like a
safe environment yeah as long as it's a
safe even if it's not that safe you know
you're like you gotta learn how to
handle yourself young man yeah well it
is a little bit like when you see like
when you see a kid who did not drink and
then they go off to college I remember
like
our valedictorian or like she was I
don't maybe she wasn't but she was a
very smart girl I was never at any of
the dumb kid parties that I was at uh
I saw her in college this girl was like
cross-eyed blackout like looking at me
with like one [__] cyborg guy the
other eyes like asleep I'm like this
girl is in trouble too yeah this girl
Percocet
exactly yeah you know who I'm talking
about uh yeah I was like she didn't
practice enough yeah you got to practice
a little bit so then when you get to the
big leagues you know how to handle your
Scandal a little bit don't practice too
much yeah you're gonna get in trouble oh
dude my friends would pick me up and I
was a lightweight son when it came to
weed early on you know they picked me up
and one of my buddies uh he drove a
church van or something or he
commandeered one or whatever I don't
know he got it but he'd show up in this
church van dude he stole a church fan
yeah yeah yeah the church let him use it
late at night okay yeah for crimes yeah
so but there was the different rows in
the church van and whatever row you in
it got more detrimental to your health
like the further to the back yeah like
the back was like people were or you
know yeah there's just like a small fire
back there everybody everybody's just
cracked out staying warm yeah and one of
the people staying warm is like an
abortion that like made it yeah yeah
yeah yeah like four day old yeah there's
a there's a failed abortion clinic in
the very back where they can't figure it
quite figure it out they keep having
babies but the front seat they're just
drinking like the hard Seltzer yeah
right yeah yeah the front seat is just
like it's like people looking at a map I
look in the direction yeah just trying
to figure out how to get back to the
church yeah yeah second seed is a hard
Seltzer yeah 13 is remedial reading that
was always remedial reading yeah so it
was like yeah because if you can't read
remediately
then you also like then you probably
can't handle a little hard Seltzer you
know what I mean or no that's not
probably the exact opposite yeah yeah so
if you can't read
you can drink hard salsa as water all
day long that's all you want to do and
it got weird yeah the further towards
the vacuum it got weirder but yeah they
would come and they would test a lot of
times they would give me the weed to
test it out you know because I was kind
of like I would fall asleep a lot of
times like if we go out I would
literally fall asleep because the weed
was real strong and then they'd wake me
up when it was literally time to go home
like I'd miss the whole night you know
oh look I had a real I had a real
sleeping disorder maybe for like six or
seven years kind of
um
uh and so anyway uh but yeah I remember
just being in my buddy's dad's van and
we would you know we would sleep in
there and just get really really high
and
um and he one of the one of the kids
dads had some sunglasses he sold
sunglasses for a living or whatever yeah
hell of a living oh yeah and with the
sun there's unlimited was he like an
Oakley rep or these were like knock
knock off no he was like a rep oh [__]
so we had all the different types you
know so that's a cool guy to know it was
pretty yeah he was pretty cool he was
cool actually I only I didn't know him
real well we would sometimes do drugs at
his house when he wasn't there yeah so
that's pretty cool it was cool we didn't
get to know him though yeah but yeah
well that's a cool dad
not home wrap around sunglasses at night
kids were doing drugs in the basement
some dad like driving cross country to
sell Oakleys yeah to like gas stations
and stuff yeah while you're doing drugs
at his houses yeah good guy well you
think he's a cool bat yeah he's a total
degenerate to other adults but to the
kids it's like pretty cool guy we're
like Todd your dad's awesome yeah yeah
Todd senior is for sure for sure awesome
but we just get weights and just urinate
all over his glasses Supply right like
at night so then like the two days later
whatever he rolls up to some place with
a bunch of just soaking wet boxes and
he's like they're selling like hotcakes
I don't know
something about the stink of these
glasses are flying off the shelves man I
feel bad about some of that [__]
yeah you know we used to there was this
girl in high school that we
I it wasn't me but we my friends would
call her Skeletor and she was a uh very
mean to us but for some reason we'd
still go to her parties and then my
friends were like pissing her parents
closets and [__] yeah
that's the main thing to do in hindsight
you're like wildly mean why are we doing
that this girl invited us to a party
yeah we're calling her a Skeletor and
pissing in closets that's kids that's
mean to [__] it's super mean yeah people
just did that kind of stuff we had some
kids bust these two gals and one of them
she had I guess kind of like why kind of
big nostrils like me and this other one
she had like a lot of gums in her smile
and they used to call them uh uh if you
take nostril and one of them they called
Mr Ed because she had longer gums and Mr
Ed if you said them backwards it was
alertsen and Derm if you set them
backwards sure so everybody always be
like oh look it's alerts and in Durham
all the time it's just so dumb but it
was like people just say it so many
times yeah and then like those girls
don't definitely couldn't put that
together you know so they're like why
are you calling us that
that's not my name
yeah it was just life man yeah God it
was fun dude yeah I remember we did a
bunch of LSD and this lady got caged up
or not lady but like a
you know someone that was the same age
as us got caged up in this room not even
caged up people said hey you're caged up
in here and then they were on so much
ass and they just believed they were
sure yeah
I'm like you went to parties and people
were in cages and we do we have to call
someone no meanwhile you could get out
whenever you want this is an unlocked
door yeah you're in a backyard it's not
even a room you're like there's no way
you can escape uh yeah I mean yeah
looking back at the [__] that we used to
do like you know the movie ma did you
ever see that movie yeah I did you know
who was in that movie Johnny Paulo who
used to work with us oh wow so my buddy
Scotty Landis wrote the movie oh wow and
it's based on I told him a story about
my childhood and he's like oh dude I
have a very similar story and it was
like I bet a lot of people do and then
he wrote that movie which essentially
was this woman who used to buy his beer
and [__] we'd go over to her apartment
she made us call her mom no yeah she'd
be like just call me Mom and you're like
huh but you're like she's buying you
beers here like hey Mom yeah can I get a
18 pack of Busch Light
and she'd like make us she would be like
wow you got us have a few here before
you can leave and so we I remember just
like
she had like this crazy like four foot
zong yeah so like there was also this
other adult man like these people were
like adults and they're just like bong
ripping with like 16 year old kids and I
like I took I took enough bong rips and
I turned like green yeah and then I lay
down in this bed like fully Zapped out
of my head and it was her like
daughter's bed her like little 13 year
old daughter and uh she she daughter
wasn't there I'm laying in the bed her
they she brings her daughter into the
room she goes it's okay just crawl into
bed with him yeah and I'm like so green
and I can't move and I just this [__]
little girl crawls into bed with me and
I'm meanwhile I'm like 16 years old and
I'm like this is too weird and then
luckily my buddies like grabbed me and
pulled me out of there and I'm like this
is a [__] horror film dude yeah cause
that is a that is a horror film that
lady could be setting you up who even
knows why is there people that are still
living that much in the past where they
are
or what do you think that is like the
mom that does that or the dad that
that's more of a ma is that more of a
mom thing or a dad thing well it might
be a dad thing but then uh that Dad is
arrested pretty quick I feel like dads
get arrested for that [__] pretty
quickly moms are like ah maybe the maybe
she is uh just being a nice woman and uh
you know yeah give him a benefit of the
dog guys immediately I think they're
like yeah he's a creep he goes to prison
uh yeah the fact that we were able to
party at This Woman's house and like
yeah it was it was it was a strange
thing every town has a couple cool kind
of cool moms like that yeah you know and
they're [__] cool dude and sometimes
they drive a van one of them I remember
drove a van with like that swimming pool
ladder on the back like what the [__]
yeah I remember that yeah why did you
yeah every time you go up there there's
no pool up there there's not a pool
there's never been a pool up there yeah
like this is a [__] weight limit it
would yeah you couldn't put a bullet
there this man's a lot yeah yeah
uh yeah I feel also vans
wear Vans yeah Vans up and disappeared
dude they were so good well my mom had a
had a a minivan that had like those
twinkly lights oh wow yeah not a fan
it's not particularly fancy it was
called a Mark III and it had like the
little lights you remember in the movie
theaters that looks like it on the top
left oh that's a Mark II yeah that's a
Mark II ours was the market oh that's
the market oh that yeah so essentially
this and then uh dumb ladder and then
there was a little like
13-inch TV with a cassette so we would
watch we'd watch Half Baked in there
yeah you know we would uh you know on
road trips I'd queue up some Forrest
Gump put that put that [__] on repeat
just run it right back
dude armor mom got a Dodge Neon car and
we'd never had like a nice car before
and we went and my brother and I would
go and sleep in it at night
and slip put the passenger seats down
and the uh driver's seat down and sleep
in there
it was so nice dude pull it up
a Dodge Neon yeah you know what I'm
talking about well yeah but that's not a
van it's just a car oh it was a van to
us man it was [__] beautiful it was
so spacious because before that she'd
had a Ford Festiva
oh yeah my uh have you ever seen those
yes my mom had they had a Buick that
right there the silver ones my mom had
that and she used to beat us and I
literally that car ran by abuse
yeah that's what it was powering my mom
could play us like the drums like she
would sit in the [__] privacy and
literally like like
and the roof would like start to droop
on you yeah like the root that's what
our my mom's car like it would like the
roof no longer the felt oh yeah it no
longer stuck to the ceiling and it would
just start to droop down and you'd be in
the back seat with like a roof like hey
like it's some swoopy bangs but it's
just the roof to the car yeah you'd be
like I hate you Mom yeah god get a car
that I could see out of
dude with that droop roof because yeah a
lot of those Vehicles had Bell's Palsy I
think yeah it's kind of sad a lot of
those Vehicles it was a different time
all right we've reached that part of the
show that nobody ever skips and this
time it's sponsored by Lucy nicotine
that's right Lucy's tobacco-free gum
pouches and Breakers are intelligent
nicotine options for upstanding
responsible adults like yourself
if you want to use nicotine and use it
responsibly
then Lucy is the way to do it
all their products have three things in
common no tobacco powerful nicotine and
delicious flavors
if that's something you're craving
you're trying to uh change the way you
consume nicotine Lucy can help
shipping is always free and there's a
30-day refund policy if you change your
mind
they sent me a bunch of products Lucy
did and and I'm looking forward to
checking some of them out I know they
have wonderful flavors like mint and
mango and people love both of those
types visit Lucy l-u-c-y dot Co and use
promo code Theo to get 20 off your first
order
if you're in the mood for some nicotine
or you're you're trying to adjust the
way you consume or you're trying to wean
off
Lucy could be a way to do that for you
Lucy products are only for adults of
legal age and every order is age
verified that's right this product
contains nicotine and nicotine is an
addictive chemical
visit lucy.co use promo code Theo to get
20 off your first order that's l-u-c-y
dot Co promo code t-h-e-o to receive 20
off and always free shipping
you know what movie I saw the other day
that I really liked was uh
um it was a Jim Carrey movie it was
called
when he owns the theater
or he goes back and gets that movie
theater Majestic you ever see that movie
oh I did but that's been so long it was
a good one that's a good I'd go back and
like just do a deep dive on all Jim
Carrey movies because he's I mean he's
the legend I won my fifth grade talent
show doing Jim Carrey Impressions no way
yeah dude can you still do anything or
no I mean no they weren't even good back
then it was just like somebody you know
it's just me doing mask uh yeah
yeah it was good
um
did you ever go to
because you moved you moved you grew up
in Omaha yeah I grew I grew up in
Waterloo Iowa until I was 10 and then we
moved to Omaha and then I until high
school and then after I graduated I
moved to uh La did you ever go to the
Field of Dreams
in Iowa yeah yeah cool isn't it it's way
cool yeah it's kind of it's in like the
middle of nowhere yeah it's just like a
baseball field yeah Dyersville it is I I
love the Midwest my mom went to school
over there in Iowa but
um
College I think oh okay
um there it is
yeah it's cool it's cool when you guys
see it it's cool yeah I I like the
Midwest people like gay people give it
such a like a bad rap but it is just
it's just people are so nice uh it's
it's like beautiful like I was a very
pretty State oh I love it like Rolling
Hills and just green beautiful Fields
you know corn fields it's cool well also
like Purina Dog brand was from there's a
lot of famous old brands that are from
there like John Deere yep
um what else oh
Russell Stover I think where's that from
God imagine knowing him Russell
I'd love it Kansas City Missouri oh yeah
I can't right there Kansas City Missouri
it's like it's like accepted as the
Midwest even though I feel like it's
getting a little wild west kind of it's
a little bit what I like about Kansas
City is like that there was like a real
Mafia element
oh yes because Sam Lewis has a mafia
Kansas City there was like the Kansas
City mob bosses and like they wouldn't
go west to there like so the mob bosses
would be in there and they would control
Vegas because they couldn't get any
closer because the the feds would come
down on them [__] at least that's what
like Casino taught me the the movie yeah
I believe a lot of that yeah I believe a
lot of that man
um is there a movie that you've been
thinking about like do you like so you
have this one done is there like another
movie that now you like do you have to
wait to see how this one does to see if
you get other opportunities how does
that kind of work in your business
because you've had a good you've had a
good run a lot of guys don't get don't
get some of the same opportunities you
know for sure uh yeah kinda you always
have to be thinking like what's the next
thing uh but yes I think this one so I
have a lot writing on this one you know
so they they Netflix really wants it to
do well I really wanted to do it well
and I think if it does well then Netflix
will let me make it a handful of more
that's great which would be great yeah
man we'll make sure July 7th we will uh
yeah so um yeah but I have like the next
couple ideas cooking right now so as
soon as the writers were on strike so I
technically I can't go pitch a movie
right now yeah so like I have it ready
to go oh and then as soon as we are not
striking any longer I'll uh I'll flop on
into that movie studio and pitch my
Wares
um do you pitch something before you
write it
yeah sometimes uh you know uh sometimes
it's you wanna
it depends every Project's like
different but sometimes if the idea is
like too weird that you feel like this
um executive wouldn't be able to to get
it
then we wouldn't I would we would just
write it and then go sell it uh but if
it's like a hooky idea like this are
they outlaws like when you you
understand the movie when I pitch it to
you so you're like oh I get it
you could just pitch that idea and
they'll buy that idea and then and then
you're kind of on the track already
um your show the gemstones are you guys
finished doing or you're just waiting to
see if you could do it again I think
we'll probably do it again I'm Danny's
pretty confident he wants to do another
couple seasons of it it's so [__] fun
dude yeah and and Dana McBride is like
I'm not you know like you said earlier
I'm just like so damn lucky to like the
that they allow me to keep doing this
[__] yeah uh and it's so ridiculous
Dana McBride is like a true comedy hero
of mine like I remember when me and the
Workaholics guys like way before we got
Workaholics when we were still doing
like internet sketch stuff uh
durs came over ander's home came over
with a DVD he like knew an agent that
slipped him a DVD of The Foot Fist Way
yeah you ever see that movie so good so
good dude and um so good Jody Hill
directed it Danny is the star of it and
Jody's just Jody right on gemstones yeah
he directs a lot of the episodes wow
what is he like he's the best dude he's
just like the coolest they're all just
the coolest nicest dudes and uh I mean
you get along so [__] good dude when
he's trying to break that but if I can
break that board yeah he's I mean so
funny and we we were writing sketches
together and we were right every
Wednesday and try to shoot something
every weekend that's that was like our
our schedule and so durs comes over and
he's like we're not gonna write anything
we're gonna watch this movie I I heard
it's it's unbelievable and we're like
all right and we watched it and we were
like holy [__] and then we watched it
right back we watched it two times in a
row and it was the first time that we
were like oh we can
not that it wasn't great because it was
great but it was like they felt like we
know those dudes like we are we can make
movies like that uh like you know what I
mean like yeah like Will Ferrell since
he does like these big characters and
his movies are like big and Broad can't
really do that yeah it felt like
unobtainable yeah and so this it felt
like oh we could make a movie like this
it feels like down and dirty and like we
could we could do this like with our
friends and then we started to that sort
of changed our idea of like what we were
doing because we were playing like more
characters or doing like bits with with
our sketches and then we're like we
should just play kind of play ourselves
yeah and that's sort of how Workaholics
like that was the start of like trying
to do sketches where I'm Adam but like
an exaggerated version of myself you
know and and then Workaholics was kind
of born out of
you guys being yourselves just in an
environment in an environment yeah yeah
it's kind of the same thing that
happened with me for podcasts and I used
to have a podcast with my friend Matt
Weiss and he worked
works with TMZ I think he still works
with them and we were interviewing
celebrities and stuff and talking about
like celebrity stuff he knew a lot about
celebrity stuff he really liked that
world and it was kind of a struggle for
me because I didn't know that much about
celebrities and then uh
then I went on Joe Rogan's show and I
left out of there one day and I was like
oh I just need to be I just need to be
myself I just need to be in a place
where I can just talk well I think
that's when Comics really start to find
their Rhythm right is when they when you
get over that hump of like
like I feel like every comic starts this
way where they just they they have their
top five comics and they try to be like
a version of them oh yeah instead of
just doing like what makes you funny
yeah who are some of yours early
of like the comics or that you do you
feel like you impersonated anybody a
little bit I know that I remember
showing a tape to a guy one time I was
doing like a year and he's like this is
great if you're like a Mitch Hedberg
impersonator
very fair yeah I bet I was doing like
some Tosh or like trying to be like
towards in or or um Jim Gaffigan was was
really big at that time and I love how
he like plays with the levels of his
voice which I still like to do but uh I
can see that now you say it a little bit
yeah so I'm so I yeah I'm sure there was
some of that and then I think like when
you start to find your voices when you
go like yeah obviously like Chris
Farley's like an influence of mine and
Jack Blackson an influence of mine and
Sandler but like
what makes me me and then and then from
then once I kind of committed to being
myself I feel like everything clicked
into place yeah and a lot of that was
from watching Foot Fist Way and being
like oh these guys are just even though
Danny isn't that guy he's like doing a
character but it's like they're doing a
character from a real place that they
can access and not
you don't have to like on your 30th
movie is when you can stretch and and
try to be something that you aren't
right right when you could be Tom Hanks
it's like Tom Hanks didn't start off
doing that yes whatever yeah Polar
Express exactly
yeah it's it's kind of fascinating man
that we all pick up pieces of other
people there's a famous book about that
it's called it's like bar I don't know
if it's called borrow but there's a book
about that we all like especially I
think in entertainment you can't help
but take influence from things like we
just interviewed Ric Flair and he talks
and he his whole his it was it was
Unreal dude I mean he is Ric Flair will
text me every year for my birthday I'm
like this is the best like no one like
my friends don't even do that [__] but
Ric Flair is like whoa Happy Birthday
Adam I love it dude
well it was so interesting but he his
his
um character his character I guess or
some of his things that you know him
from their amalgamation of other people
right and he says it's not any talking
at a shop and he kind of like fine-tuned
him you know it's just interesting
that's how everything works kind of well
it's also like the generation of comics
that you come up with like if you're
rolling with a crew you all are like
kind of taking from each other like
without even it's like how groups of
friends when you guys are kids how like
that group of friends they all have the
same terminology they all have the same
verbiage like they talk alike they dress
alike and you just can't help but but be
like that yeah that's just human nature
so like when people [__] on me for you
know talking like this person or being
like that person I'm like I'm friends
with those guys like this is just how we
talk right and some of it's paying
homage to them in some type of way you
know it's like you're kind of it's like
you're as long as you're not stealing
like their jokes or like fully like I
bet you would be like yo Adam what's
with the mullet if I like get your exact
same hair and I started like doing like
your type of material you might be like
what the [__] Divine yeah but like and
if you got held back in the sixth grade
yeah if I if I demanded to be held back
in the sixth grade to be more like you
yeah
and they're like but Adam you can read
and do basic math and I'm like [__]
hold me back hold me back so I can be a
[__] King yeah I'm trying to be the
Rat King dude bro it's crazy that people
just let their kids go through all the
great like hold your kid back one year
yeah and make him a [__] Legend I I
remember
the kid that I was like my bully it's
funny I've said on multiple podcasts
that he was my bullet and then my aunt
won Thanksgiving comes up to me and goes
Adam can I talk to you and I'm like yeah
what's up and she goes do you remember
Brian I'm not going to say his last name
uh and I'm like yeah dude that kid was
my bully in elementary school and she
goes he says that you were his bully and
that you really picked on him when you
were a kid but this was a kid that he
like failed a grade in my fourth grade
or whatever and was held back so he's
like way bigger than me he had like
facial hair in the fourth grade he was
like and and he was drawn it on but he
had it yeah he had it and he kept
picking on me and I remember like my dad
was like is he bigger than you I'm like
yeah and he goes well then violence is
your only key and I'm like what and he's
like you have to strike first and strike
often and I'm like this is some bad
advice
totally so like I just I like punch this
kid in the face like he said some [__] I
just like [__] whacked him and then
would run away be like so where he could
never Strike Back I kicked him down a
staircase once like so I was like a
violent little kid and in hindsight I
was this kid it's bullied but from my
point of view he bullied me and then my
dad just gave me the go-ahead to be a
violent little [__] and so I'm sorry
Brian I didn't know dude I thought you
were my bully and I was trying to stand
up for myself yeah we didn't know Brian
bullies are regular people I saw that
song dude God sometimes
and I pray for them
damn
we got to get you in a Pitch Perfect
movie they don't make good music anymore
huh how many how how perfect are you
guys gonna make the pitch that's what a
lot of people are wondering yeah is it
isn't it perfect people are saying it's
like when Step It Up keeps coming up
people like how yes they're sticking up
to the streets like we get it how many
places to say that how much should we
how much do we have to step it up yes
yeah yeah how perfect is the pitch gonna
get do you think will it it's still
getting dude I'm doing a spin-off show I
did uh it's called Bumper in Berlin
season one is already airing on peacock
it was a [__] hit for them and then
uh yeah so I lived in Germany all last
year for like four months last year and
like just being a song and dance man in
Germany dude there yeah there's there's
me uh that girl has horns on her head
yeah it's a wild show
um
in it
no dude that sucks you're right I should
put riff in it
uh
yeah so yeah the pitch the pitch is
still staying perfect dude I'm I'm
riding that one all the way home wow
that's cool yeah that's what interesting
I mean just followed an interesting life
man because the ghosting in Germany for
four months is pretty you have to work
every single day or do you actually have
some free time yeah I worked a lot on
that one because I was the lead of it
and it's like a song and dance show so
like I'm singing and dancing every
goddamn episode so like I have thought
on the weekends it's like I have to go
record songs and I have to like learn
choreography and [__] and then uh but it
was a wild that's have you ever been to
Germany
um
yes okay
uh yes I have my girlfriend Somebody
almost ran over my girlfriend with a
bike over there oh dang where at
um I don't know it's about like this
little
uh
it's kind of like by a uh
I don't know what it was I don't
remember I mean I remember but I don't
remember enough to say anything else
yeah I've been there
not as a dangerous intersection yes yeah
dangerous intersection uh yeah so we
were in Berlin and awesome City super
fun but like also like kind of cool in a
weird way where like uh they have this
club bergheim which is like the cool
Club where like everyone wears like
leather
dig pouches and [__] and they have this
guy that they call him the um piss
Goblin and he's like a 65 year old man
and like you're supposed to just piss on
him when you see him oh wow yeah and
he's in a chair is he sitting down no
he'll just like well I I didn't go to
this club but I've been told all about
him and then he'll just like go around
the club and uh yeah that's it right
there the big Square building yeah and
uh and then it's just a warehouse inside
and uh yeah it's scary it's like
industrial
um type music and then and then the piss
Goblin will like lay in the the trough
you know how they have troughs at uh in
men's shitty men's bathrooms yeah and uh
he'll just lay in there and be like
you can just splash him up you just
splash them up apparently yeah freaking
put a batch on that dude so it was like
kovid was just starting to like wind
down at that point and so all the clubs
were closed and then while I was there
they all opened and we were getting sat
at this nice restaurant my wife Chloe
and I and um the guy recognized me he's
talking to me and he's like oh you
enjoying Germany and I'm like oh you
know we really like it he's like have
you been to some of the clubs they're so
fun and crazy and we're like oh we
haven't yet you know I'm working a lot
so don't have time to go to the clubs
and he goes oh it's so fun you have to
make the time
um this awesome parties the piss parties
and then he goes okay your table's ready
just so quickly the piss parties okay
table's ready you can sit down you
here's some charcuterie yeah here's some
ginger soup yeah here's some ginger soup
enjoy the piss party well dude piss
pigging is a big thing I think now it
used to
um and even vegans are doing it I think
it's like piss pigging is I guess when
there's like a fella at like a what's
pigging what's piss pigging can you
bring something up Zach you're leaving
on a branch here brother
um it's when people are drinking urine I
think somewhere oh and like it's like
rich I think I don't know if it's rich
people do it but it's like uh his Pig
yeah let's only get porn don't look at
porn please
but I mean well it's hard it's hard not
to look at porn with the piss pigging
because it's probably pretty synonymous
with it's like you look up butt [__]
you're gonna see some butt [__] then
you know dude yeah you know it's like
you look up fish big and you're gonna
see some piss pigs all right whatever
man that's that's how you guys are gonna
be about it I'm just looking for more of
a technical site okay
like I don't want to see that I don't
want to hear the symphony I just want to
read the sheet music
but I think it's people that will drink
urine so it's like at these high-end
parties I'm hearing you can go around
and you pay somebody and then you just
urinate into them and it's like uh and
people enjoy it I guess
um but that's something that's going on
but I think in Germany they're very they
don't
things aren't as taboo to them is that
what it felt like or it's more taboo
well I feel like in Berlin especially
it's like the the freak you are the the
cooler it is and everyone's just very
open-minded yeah and so like I was
staying at the Soho house right in like
in East Berlin very nice hotel they have
this awesome rooftop uh bar that that we
would eat dinner up there A lot of times
and uh we were having drinks late one
night and it was like it wasn't even
that late it was like 11 o'clock and but
people go they have dinner at like 11
and then they go to the clubs at like
midnight one and then they stay there
all night long and there's full-on dudes
in like leather straps with like their
nipples like pierced and then a chain
connecting then a chain going down yeah
and he's just full-on sitting there
eating a full rotisserie chicken oh yeah
just to not get up I'm like that is you
don't see that in La you know no you
don't see that oh yeah oh here we go
you're there's a social media community
of people drinking bathing in their yarn
for the sake of Health uh so you bathe
in your own urine I feel like
I'm going to say no to that yeah I'm
going to give that a no too
highlights from the urine therapy whoa
whoa okay so this lady and this lady or
also this could be that guy Bill what's
his name that used to play for the
Lakers
lambeer the Walton Bill Walton does he
she looks like him alone oh yeah that's
Bill Walton now I'm just saying I don't
know I thought who knows yeah who knows
yeah and no shade to Bill or Luke I
don't know there's just this could be AI
yeah that's true you can't trust
anything anymore but dude if somebody
rolled up on you with first of all also
Imagine because that woman she's it said
59 years old she said she was uh imagine
being
yeah 59 this month uh
uh imagine because that could be your
mom you know yeah imagine your mom get
has like a little Health kick
like moms sometimes do my mom has them
all yeah yeah where you're like yeah
I've got got really into salads or
whatever and you're like good for you I
like that for you you know try to live
as long as you can but then she your mom
like those full-on like I guzzle my own
piss that'd be a bummer she's like
trying to give you hugs and and like
little cheek smooches you know as moms
do oh yeah she has like a breath of her
own piss that would suck that'd be like
oh that'd be a real bummer that's that
movie yeah it's like the sequel to that
movie Backdraft kind of but what about
this brother right there soaking his uh
feed in some urine and letting the dog
lick him oh yeah well this man should be
arrested
this guy has to go right to prison uh
and that that woman too Mom you got to
go to you got to go to jail this is a
bad idea yeah I feel
anyone else's month old urine tastes
exactly like beer nah dude well you're
drinking for sure bad beer yeah that's
bad yeah that's bad really bad beer
like you could just spend like one
dollar more and get beer that doesn't
taste like month old yearn yeah non-pit
no piss in here but what if what if yeah
what if that's the like Bud Light's new
slogan they're trying to gain some some
drinkers back no piss in here buddy
um is your wife an actress too she is
yeah she is yeah she's very beautiful
lady you posted you guys post a lot of
pictures and do a lot of fun stuff
together it looks like we do when we
tried to do a bunch of fun stuff did you
guys kind of fall in love what was that
like for you because you seem like
you're in love kind of that's the vibe
that I get from you yeah I hope when you
marry someone you're you're in love
that's the that's the the key to the to
the whole thing I think but some people
don't put their they you know they don't
yeah because they don't want to yeah I'm
like a very I feel you know because we
want to have kids and stuff and some
people I have friends that they like
don't put their kids on their social
media I think I'm just gonna put my kids
all over I don't give a [__] I just like
my life like I'm a pretty open book I'm
like yeah this is my wife these are my
friends doesn't my kid
I don't kidnap the kid obviously that's
a prerequisite oh yeah yeah that's a
definitely No-No but it's like but even
stalkers aren't that back in the day I
think a stalker would come to kid like
stalkers even nowadays they're kind of
people don't give a [__] about me that's
what's cool about comedians it's like
there's no real no one really cares it's
a good point huh you know like it's like
when these people see you at the
Starbucks
or see me they're they're just like oh
[__] what's up man yeah
you you want some extra pumps of
sugar-free vanilla yeah like that's what
I get you know or like yo this one's on
the house I'm like no dude I can pay for
the coffee and they're like I got you
yeah that's the level of stalker that I
have just like a cool guy who's a
barista but then when that dude shows up
later in your living room and he's like
yeah this one's on that yes you owe me
for that cold brew bro that would almost
be a crazy movie like a unique stalker
that like just show it like who just
wants to brew me espressos yeah yeah he
gives you one free thing and you don't
even want it and then he holds that
against you forever that's like that
sounds like a Black Mirror episode yeah
where he just you're like I didn't even
want the egg white and ham sandwich that
you that you made me get
it's like I actually had breakfast homie
I didn't even want this but
but all right I had a woman hit me after
a show Once uh stop me after a show one
time and ask her if I was leaving
subliminal messages and podcasts to her
and that was kind of crazy and she was
extremely serious
she was extremely serious that's scary
it was way scary but you were right
it was I haven't been but you're gonna
start yes three M M's three M M's
whatever that means to her uh
um yeah I had one time and this was
really early on nothing this weird has
happened since but this girl brought me
a bunch of cupcakes to a show and this
was like right when Workaholics was
taking off and I'm like
this is the best I get baked goods now
I'm at baked good level and so I like
take I was living with Blake at a time
we had just rented this like cool house
in the Hollywood Hills and I come back
and I'm like Yo dude I got these
cupcakes like I'm at baked goods level
and I like bit into a cupcake it was the
first cupcake I bet into chunk of her
hair dude
like a full-on
tendril like like a lock like a lock
like she cut off a little chunk baked it
into a cupcake it's so
how [__] weird is that dude I mean I
what is what is she getting out of that
and then now I'm like well now I can't
that sucks because I want to be able to
eat baked goods from fans I want to be
able to accept this polish romance I
think dude the delicious you know treats
that are given to me but but now you can
you never know God that's wild to have
somebody's hair in there yeah I guess I
guess it was like
I'd rather have hair than just like
they just a ton of fentanyl or some [__]
oh yeah you know like that's for sure
better but but still they had our Taco
Bell in our town was famous somebody had
been doing like Duty and the meat or
whatever whenever it first opened up and
I know this people say this is an old
wives tale dude this is a true story
okay and they had and I know people say
this happened in our town whatever they
shut our Taco Bell down for two months
bro and people were losing their [__]
minds people were getting divorces
outside of it people were throwing
bricks through the window
um people were right so so people were
because the I think the old wives tale
was like they used uh like dog meat or
something and you're like what no but I
love a Cheesy Gordita Crunch how could
they do this
um but then that's not that wasn't like
a real thing so people were literally
like a guy who was working busted a guy
doing Duty in the meat and you can look
it up too I think buddy but this was um
yeah they oh yeah in my town I don't
think anybody's gonna frown at half a
pound of of
raw Bichon or something you know what
I'm saying but I think somebody goes and
feces up a meat you know somebody yeah
and feasty up a uh one of those you know
um what are they Crunchwrap Supremes or
whatever yeah
but that's where that really happened in
our town you know and it's unfortunate
that that kind of stuff happened but
that sucks can you find it it may be on
a Reddit I think I found the article
it's just loading I feel uh 1997.
it's an old article bro good year can't
believe it happened dude I remember one
night I got out of my buddy's piss man
with the sunglasses I was so high they
woke me up because we stopped at Taco
Bell and I got out and
I went to live with this other family in
high school and I get out and they were
there and I was like you ever be so high
and you see some people you're like I'm
not supposed to see these people when
I'm high oh dude yeah absolutely it's
the worst that's the worst uh
yeah that's the worst God it was the
worst man dude what's up I like said
what like it's something yeah
and they're like hey Theo good to see
you it's lasagna tonight
oh good love lasagna yeah my agents
called me in the uh the other week they
called me like at eight o'clock at night
and I had alarming I like smoked weed
and then they called right then and then
it's like the whole team and I like just
change agencies and they're like they're
just wanting to talk to me about stuff
and like career stuff man I did I I just
talked for like 12 minutes straight
didn't let them get a word in it's just
me like saying words yeah that I don't
know even the meaning of
I'm just saying [__] dude afterwards I
was I like call my manager I'm like was
I just saying a bunch of words it's like
yeah dude you were Megan so I'm like
[__]
don't don't call me
don't call me at eight like that's a
that's an afternoon it's outside of
sober hours for sure
I might I might have just smoked a joint
in which case I'm gonna
I'm gonna be spinning my wheels in the
mud yeah in the in the
vocabulary money oh yeah I think
especially if agents they deserve to
hear something from you every now and
then even if you call them like Hey
listen to me read a little bit of this
stuff that I wrote and you just read
like the first chapter of like uh
um scarlet letter to him yeah they would
love that they would love you using
their time like that and they'll stay on
the phone they were doing well enough
yeah they'll stay on the [__] phone
they will yeah they'll stay on there and
be like wow that's interesting uh wow
good stuff and this is because uh
are you gonna are you gonna write a book
I know a lot of comics are writing books
yeah I thought about I've written a
bunch over the years I've written a lot
I mean I've probably written half of a
book for sure I think sometimes I'd read
your book I bet you know you got so many
tales from thanks man from your uh youth
we grew up in a unique area man Ian
Somerhalder was from our town you ever
met him uh show me him we I his name is
so familiar God he was handsome brother
really nobody ever seen it oh yeah that
yo yeah no I know this guy this guy uh
was in The Vampire Diaries with uh with
my girl Nina Dobrev I mean if you're
able to be
I mean he's almost he's could be man or
woman yeah you're so hot yeah you could
be either like that's when you are the
peak level like Brad Pitt
put long hair give them tits that's a
that's a beautiful woman he's at least
an eight as a woman this guy though has
that he him and yeah you might be right
this he's yeah he's got more uh maybe
not I don't know I guess it depends on
what kind of woman you're into
that's a sexy lady yeah but I mean he
was like they had the most hand he was
like the most hand the most handsome so
he is he like right around your age so
you like knew this guy he was maybe a
little bit older than me but we heard
about him yeah he's he was so hot he
went to another school and you're like
word is so there's just like a hot boy
here's what he would do though this is
the biggest Flex ever he would come to
school the first day of school and then
go back to like being like a model or
superhero so he would just come the
first day so all the chicks could see
him yeah like there he is there he is
and meanwhile us regular dudes we got on
everything we could yeah we put cologne
and a couple of choice Spots You're Just
reeking of Cool Water cologne oh we'd
[__] done it all we use the annual
mouthwash we done it all we were ready
you got your uh what were the like cool
jeans like Jabo probably some jabos baby
or
um duck head maybe something like you
know he'd had something [__] decent
our [__] was American Eagle dungarees oh
where it had like a little thing to like
put your Hammer oh yeah
like like you always just had a hammer
ready to go yeah yeah never used it
never needed a hammer but then you bring
a hammer and hit somebody with it yeah
and you're like suddenly you have to go
to in-school detention yeah suddenly
you're uh the criminal yeah those are
the sick genes that uh yeah yeah 28
that's fair
pretty reasonable price yeah I don't
know why my mom is being such a goddamn
[__] about buying me these jeans
they're 28 lady and that was in what 98
99 like that was yeah I feel like uh
those were good man there were probably
11 then you know yeah yeah if they're 28
now
yeah I'm trying to think of what other
big clothes was popular then probably oh
dude for me it was a it was a lot of no
fear you didn't want to have any fear on
your on you wanted people to know from
like across the room that you do not
possess any fear yeah none oh if you had
a [__] ounce of fear in you
yeah you better not have any fear and
you want everyone to know that there's
yeah and you have no none absolutely
none remember the eyes remember that
little eyes thing every [__] hard had
that oh yeah dude absolutely remember
and then and then Massimo was uh was
another big one awesome that was big bro
yeah dude I feel like you might have had
some money if you rocked a Massimo sure
yeah I didn't my my family wouldn't hook
me up with uh with a Massimo I did that
one that was like
it was like uh they made it hard to see
it said Massimo but then like the way
they was like blurred vision yeah yeah
they had um I remember some uh I would
always end up living with buddies and so
I would use their [__] you know oh so
you you kind of had a revolving closet a
little bit but I would always be like oh
man I can't find your shirt but they
don't have to wear I'd be at school with
them they're like oh this is okay you're
like I was really looking for that shirt
have you seen it Theo and you're like
no
haven't I'd wear my backpack on the
front in the Halls
just the dumbest dude oh that's funny so
did you go through any like phases you
know like uh yes bro I went through did
you go through like a goth phase yes oh
I love that for you dude I went through
it and we had the boot like the kind of
like uh what were those shoes Dr Martin
oh yeah Doc Martens yeah yeah I had some
of them so we had those it made you a
little taller that was that was big for
me I was always kind of the short kid so
I was like it leveled me up a little bit
yeah that's good yeah for you though
because yeah I was afraid of heights I
didn't love have having them on yeah but
I you can't fall from Such Great Heights
all uh all four feet 11 inches to Tumble
to the ground uh
um but I remember those what I remember
like the uh the hemp necklaces that had
like the little silver balls in the hemp
you don't do it I know what you're
talking about I I was at home making
them I would I'd go home I figured out
how to make them I'd go home and and
make them I'll like not do my homework
and just make necklaces listen to Bush
razor blade suitcase on on my CDs games
and just [__] I don't think my mom
was thinking I was just in there just
inhaling weed smoke but like I didn't
even smoke I was just like all about
like hacky sacking and making them
necklaces dude hacky sack was so much
fun I was I was pretty dude dude you
know uh just stall it on your ball
install here and then yeah and and you
always have to look around as if like
can you believe I [__] caught it it's
right here ladies
it was just like some long hair dude
that you yeah yeah
one girl was just like a mouthful of
braces it's like wow that's really cool
yeah brother was nothing better and
worse than the hacky side Circle there
was always like two kids that didn't
even know how to speak I feel like in it
yeah and then there were lights out yeah
or it's just like the nerdy kid who like
never played any sports and then he just
appears in the hacky sack Circle and
you're like whoa hey Brian what's
what's up dog yeah you want to play and
he's like oh sure and then he's just a
Phenom dude oh you know he's Pele with
it he's got his foot Foot Skills on
points
we had a kid this real pasty kid I mean
he was just
God he probably I don't know if he had
any blood in him you know he was so
white like if you wanted to see color in
his skin you had to squeeze the blood up
to one side so you would do that you
always wanted to see blood but he broke
out and did Michael Jackson one time in
the cafeteria and shocked the world oh
my God that was my favorite scene like
the kid who like never talked and then
like during the talent show he likes is
setting up his drum kit and you're like
what the [__] yeah this kid and Randall
has drums yeah Randall has drums and
then he's like oh this is just a little
something that I like to do when I'm at
home and everyone's like okay Randall
let's see let's see this and then then
he's just [__]
he's Travis Barker on that [__] just
beating them skins
oh he played the national anthem oh [__]
and you just started saluting he's not
even playing the national anthem you're
just saluting him yeah suddenly he just
levels up oh
he just shows up sets up his drum kit
[__] whales yeah thank you goodbye
keep the drum kit I'm gonna go be a
model god dude and we're all [__] gel
and it was the worst though because he
came and it was like he just set the bar
for what none of us could be handsome
wise to the girls you know and it was
just there was a kid in my high school
uh Mike McCoy and he's handsome super
cool super cool looking would hang out
with like college kids when we were
freshmen in high school how how dude he
uh how did he do it how did he do it he
could dunk a basketball in eighth grade
no yeah just the coolest I remember one
time me and my homie Nick Hoagie were uh
were
walking through I flipped some kids off
because I was a bad boy oh yeah and
these kids were gonna just beat my ass
and they were older and I'm like oh [__]
and my homie Nick Hoagie was a big kid
so we like uh we tried to get over this
fence I hop over the fence he couldn't
get over the fence and I'm like so I had
to hop back over the fence and I'm like
well I'm not gonna let him get his ass
kicked it'll be solidarity you know oh
wow and so I hop back over and like all
right and uh these kids are like you
better be careful who you're flipping
flipping off and I'm like yeah I know
we're gonna get our asses Kate and then
I just hear nah
through the masses and then the the
[__] crew parts and Mike McCoy comes
through and he's like nah they're cool
and these older kids Mike's our age yeah
and uh there's older kids like you sure
Mike and he's like yeah they're cool be
careful who you're flipping off you
better not do this [__] ever again and
we're like oh
I'm like how cool is that damn he stood
up for you standing up for us and then
they listen to him that's cool what's up
Mike how's it going man good day thank
you Mike yeah thanks Mike thanks for
being that guy yeah he's a good guy
there's ways that you people can use
they're cool that they don't realize
sometimes I think yeah he was all he was
just always a leader of men and then he
uh yeah and then he end up he's like
he's in the military in a badass fashion
somehow I don't exactly know what he's
doing but like there's photos of him
like jumping out of helicopters holding
assault rifles yeah like cool [__] right
you know so we had this we had this kid
named Nathaniel and he told everybody
like he was an undercover cop or
something and he wasn't and um a bunch
of people beat the [__] out
different story yeah but yeah
he had like a fake balak he one day
pulled out he's like yeah well I gotta
surprise you guys I'm a [__]
undercover cop he's like [__] you
Nathaniel yeah this is a 21 Jump Street
[__] you're not undercover I've known
you since the fourth grade you're not an
undercover cop yeah dude you just failed
spelling dude you're not a [__] yeah
yeah spell officer [__] you can
there's no cue in it you dumb [__]
oh it was fun man
um yeah do you think about having
children do you guys have a plan for it
or what do you once you get married you
have to make a plan to have children or
how does that kind of just I guess you
have to talk about it with your spouse
you do there is a conversation and then
and then it's like
uh getting off of the birth control and
that takes like a few months to get out
of your system and then and then it's uh
you know then it's game on you got a
plan huh
I'm like
there can be too much of a plan because
like it's life baby yeah it's just gonna
happen and then and then you just have
to then you're gonna have like a homie
that you like have to take care of
yeah which is you know
because I'm you know I'm 39 years old
now and like to go this long without
having to take care of a little homie is
uh you know because I've like a lot of
my friends they had kids like Blake and
honors had kids almost a decade ago now
no so they already have like true little
people that they take care of that are
like buddies playing sports wow you know
do you feel behind the curve
nah because I mean like I feel like I
also have a whole other group of friends
that haven't yet yeah so
yeah and work sometimes keeps you busy
you know yeah for me I was like I wanted
to be
uh set up enough that when I do have
kids like I it's I don't have to feel
like I uh
like I know what I can pass on and what
there was a point where I was like I
have to be on the road all the time I
have to be doing I have to have a TV
show I have to have a stand-up show I
have to have like I have to do all these
things to get to the place that I want
to be and then now I'm like okay like I
could set up a movie and I'm confident
enough that I'll get another opportunity
to come I don't have to jump on
everything yeah there will be also I'll
have more time to be
a good dad because you know that's
pretty important oh I think it's going
to be key probably yeah did was there um
yeah I guess it's kind of nice to be it
is nice to be able to say I don't want I
don't want to do that
yeah and feel like
there it used to be like
you you would think like oh if I don't
do that someone else is going to do that
and then
that I would have lost out on that
opportunity right when now it's like
it's fine someone else can do it
right it's just not it just wasn't for
me yeah or I don't I want to have the
summer to do XYZ like that is more
important than this right now yeah and I
think like just career-wise right now I
feel like I'm in a place where like I
can
um pick and choose a little more than I
used to be able to congrats man it's
real cool yeah thanks I mean you too you
know I bet it's the same with the
podcast world that you've built it's uh
it's nice to yeah I remember when it was
taken off for you for you and I saw you
at the um in the hallway of the Improv
and I remember being like
just knowing that your standup was
really taking off and I was like is it
your Netflix special like did your
special come out and like kind of blew
you up because I think I was gearing up
to do my Netflix special and you were
like no it was really the podcast the
podcast is what what it was yeah yeah
and I just I was like oh that's sick
like I'd seen all you guys you and you
know sagura and
yeah it's a whole world yeah it's
interesting to have a whole world you
know
um and I think yeah it's like it's
interesting to have so many different
people in here get to it's interesting
that it almost gave everybody else a
different Hollywood or a lot of people a
different type of Hollywood you know we
just kind of get to communicate
um get to sit and chat with people too
you know and catch up that's fine I talk
to some of my heroes yeah fun to be able
to uh
what I think is cool about podcasts is
it's like it just gives people an
opportunity to go like I wonder what my
favorite Comics how they are when
they're not are they funny just off the
cuff or do they have to like write
everything down it just gives them a
opportunity to pee behind the curtain of
like what is kind of like to sit in the
back of a comedy club with you know with
comedian peers yeah you know and it's
not like we would sit down and have like
an hour-long conversation in the back of
a comedy club because you gotta do your
set but it's like it gives people a
little peek yeah
yeah it's interesting man it's
interesting to see uh it's interesting
here I like listening to some pods and
I'm like oh wow this is this is good you
know I mean it's just it's it's nice to
be able to talk about things it's nice
to be able to see where somebody's
career is at how some things have kind
of happened for them people's lives get
so busy too I've started to realize that
sometimes when I sit down with someone a
podcast it may be the only time I'm
gonna get to talk to them for a while
yeah so to make you know to sort of
really try and make the time have some
um value uh not only to listeners but
you know just just like between me and
them
um what's like uh you know there's like
some meme going around of like
I don't know of like showing like kids
playing and then it's like at some point
you're gonna go out and play with your
friends and that'll be the last time you
played with your friends in your
childhood and you're like oh yeah and
it's sort of the same with like
comics where we all kind of were in the
same
circles when we were starting out at the
comedy store at The Improv the laugh
Factor wherever and you just see the
same people over and over and over and
over and over again and then all of a
sudden something happens in someone's
career and it takes them this way or
that way and then you no longer see
those people because it's probably been
years since I've seen you yeah so like
it's it's cool for the podcast world to
be able to sit down with people that you
respect and like and uh and have
conversations with them yeah and and get
to catch up with with people that uh you
always liked even if you only ever saw
them for 15 minutes in the back at
comedy clubs once a week yeah
um
I don't know what to say after that Zach
do we have any other good news was there
anything else that we were looking at in
the news that was interesting
um yeah well uh so it looks they just
tweeted this photo last night of Elon
Musk is training for his fight with Mark
Zuckerberg
that's awesome that he's training I love
it and I really want to see this fight
because it it will be entertaining
regardless of how good of a fight it is
uh
I thought I read something about how
Elon musk's mom
doesn't want him to fight and came out
and said like the fight is canceled wow
but maybe that's fake news I don't know
I have no idea um yeah I mean it's hard
to know these days what is news what is
being used as like a ploy to push
something
um I think that don't encourage this
match Maya Musk
okay
wow well I think she must know that Elon
I think they say that Zuckerberg can
actually
compete
Mark Zuckerberg he's
a lot younger than Elon right he's only
five seven now elon's 5 10 or 11. I
don't know the weight difference but if
you have a guy that's really strong that
small I think he's going to defeat a guy
that's weaker that's big well and also
Elon isn't known for being like a
fighter at all and I feel like no I feel
he's like he's like in the Jeff uh Bezos
Camp of like he got rich and then now he
just
space food and treats his body like a
temple yeah I mean Mark hasn't blinked
probably since 91 or 92. yeah I think he
had the surgery
I mean you can see that he's writing an
algorithm with his [__] eyes bro yeah
dude he isn't he is human AI right there
it totally is there's no doubt about it
he very much has an AI look and Elon
looks I think I just don't I don't know
how Elon wins but
if Elon is low-key
I mean you don't even look at he's
holding his boxing gloves correctly if
you look at the boxing gloves picture
yeah he's that chin is way out there
buddy yeah that's a great Point even
just right there yeah
and also the age difference that is
something oh that'll wear you oh yeah
yeah uh
but Elon has a gas he ain't stay up all
night and they gotta tweet it freaking
yeah yeah you're right he's got gas in
the tank so maybe I'm excited to see
he's also a lot heavier it's true so you
know it's a good point you just lay it
on top of him you might win it's a good
point yeah I think it's just getting
interesting in the world this is the
type of stuff you're starting to see and
we talked about this years ago about
everything becoming WWE you know
everything becoming matches it's like
you have uh you know Jake Paul and Nate
Diaz they're gonna fight you know you
have potentially I mean this has
potential you know like Dana White
wouldn't waste his time on the
communicating with these guys
um no I mean I would I want to see it
like it is it is weird
it sort of feels like Hunger Games or
some [__] like where like they used to
make movies or like in a world where
yeah where the two richest men in the
world just duke it out uh it feels fake
you know and it feels it's so weird now
that like
like if me and you wanted to just fight
there we could fight and then we could
like be at Staples Center fighting when
it used to be like you used to have to
be a fighter you would like have to go
through
training for it and just be like me and
you were like yeah similarly built it'd
be like yeah
Theo's got the reach but Adam could get
inside and then and we could be at least
on an undercard yeah we could be on an
undercard we could be an undercard for
probably like oh maybe who else could go
who who else would be on that card
I'd like to see Josh Jamel against
somebody
I could I could he's he's a big man too
he's got that long reach big him versus
Dax Shepard
[__] that's a Bangarang right there
yeah we're the undercar people people
are trickling in for us yeah they're
trickling in they're they're like still
or getting their their drinks and their
their foot long Dodger Dog yeah
somebody's explaining to his wife who we
are yeah yeah yeah yeah showing Clips
she's like oh I saw
bumper from Pitch Perfect is fighting
the podcaster guy
yeah yeah honey it's gonna get better
honey
better if it'll get better it's just me
and you just just dancing around each
other neither of us really wants to
throw a punch you break it as I hit you
once you break in a song
I spin off
and then who else is on that card who's
under us you said bang rang what if you
went like old like a Rufio type of like
versus Emmanuel Lewis Maybe
oh is Emmanuel Lewis dead
but hey we want to put that out there if
he's not hey sorry whoever brought
Pink's mom to the show they can throw
them on stage yeah that's his promoter
so
52 52. all right
versus Rufio so if you had them too and
we need a good female bout on the card
too
yes absolutely uh
Jane Lynch Amy Schumer oh I like that
that's fun
Jane's a little older but she's she's a
tall woman she's longer she's longer and
she could she looks like she could go
through a [__] like she could run
through a wall that lady oh she looks
like the like a wind chime that'll beat
the [__] out of some music that is
exactly what she looks like that's a
perfect description of Jane Lynch
um it'd be fun man
um what else anything else Zach or do
you think we covered a lot of neat stuff
do we cover neat stuff Zach I think we
covered some neat stuff dude yeah learn
about piss picks that was informative oh
that's so heartbreaking
yeah we couldn't really look it up
because it is pretty pornographic thank
God and I have the blockers too on my
phone and computer
um
but the movie is July 7th that's right
July 7th The Outlaws we want to go watch
it and what do what do consumers need to
think about when they go watch stuff
like and how it affects what other
movies are going to be created because I
feel like that's starting to become like
it's always been a thing but with only
so many comedies being created last year
that's unbelievable it sucks dude it
sucks uh and luckily like Netflix is one
of the places that is just willing to
roll the dice a little more than than
other places because it matters
so much less like like like the machine
and Sebastian's movie um about my father
I think uh the fact that they put both
of those movies out on the same weekend
I'm like that [__] sucks because like
you're putting down six movies all year
long and then you put two of them out on
the same weekend and so like if you're
gonna go see a comedy you had to choose
between these two and then when those
movies only make eight million dollars
or whatever opening weekend well you're
like well if it was only the one movie
maybe could have made 14. could have
made yeah 15 16 and then that's a
healthy amount for it to make but right
yeah so uh
so yeah support if you like comedy
support comedies watch it tell your
friends to watch it
um and then and then we'll have the
opportunity to make more of them and and
it used to be you know well people were
like well if you made better comedies
then and it's like sure but it's hard to
make a movie first of all it's really
hard and secondly uh there used to be
like 40 shots and making a good comedy
and then maybe two or three of them were
a classic comedy and you're like
well that old school and it came out
you're like well there was 28 other
movies that weren't old school that came
out that year you know what I mean right
so the more opportunities we have to
make classic comedies the the more we'll
be able to to nail it but I I do think
Outlaws uh has a potential to be one of
those type of movies so I'm really proud
of it do you think of um do you start to
think of do creating a movie entirely of
your own like or partnering with
somebody and using your like do you or
and doing it direct to Consumer does
that ever start to become a discussable
model maybe not in your space I mean
you're kind of a yeah just because it's
the movies I want to make are usually
like action comedies and they are you
need money I I need money like I don't
have 30 million dollars of my own money
to invest in the movie right uh so yeah
you need a big deal yeah and you need a
partner and then also like it costs a
lot to promote a movie too like that's
where people forget like buying TV
commercials to play during basketball
games and like things that people are
actually watching live that costs a
fortune yeah and to put Billboards up
and to have you know radio commercials
and like to get the word out there like
I don't I don't have that infrastructure
so like Workaholics movie we were gonna
do a Workaholics movie and we were five
weeks out from shooting uh you'd already
written it already written it we're in
pre-production had offices we're
building sets had the whole cast and
crew coming back and we're gonna shoot
it here in L.A wow and then at the top
of this year Paramount Plus
said it didn't and they like went off on
like uh you know the holiday break and
when they came back they were like you
know what we have a new Global agenda
and we don't feel that workhogs fits the
global agenda and they pulled the plug
from us no and everyone's like just make
the movie on your own it was like we
don't have that much money to you know
we're not billionaires we like we don't
have that kind of coin so like
now it's just and they own the rights to
it too so we couldn't even anyways so
yeah we just all that all that work for
for nothing how did and that I mean that
just goes to show you how hard it is why
people don't
I can't imagine that movie I can't
imagine that not getting made I can't
imagine if you're going to find a brand
that people love yeah that that would
not that they would not think that that
would have an audience it was so
heartbreaking because it was uh
I did get to write a really funny press
release though about just I said butt
hurt like 15 times and then like how
butt hurt I am that they pulled the
block which I'm I'm it was funny to see
like a variety and The Hollywood
Reporter saying Adam DeVine says he's
very butt hurt that the Paramount plus
canceled the work Alex movie but uh they
they like were gassing us up they're
like this is the home for Workaholics we
want to build out the Workaholics
Universe yeah and they're like we want
to do like a spin-off show that you guys
executive produce maybe we do an
animated project we'll do the movie like
we want your brand of Comedy to live on
Paramount plus and we're like thank God
like we have a home base that we could
just go to we can make all of our stuff
there we can if people love it we could
keep the Workaholics family alive like
so many friends and and you know people
that worked on the show that that would
like that was going to be their
opportunity and then they just pulled
the rug out from us so God super butt
hurt about it but
um
[Music]
anything else exactly anything
that's unreal man yeah it just shows you
how hard it is to get something Pat I
just like dude people not it's almost
like if it doesn't have Global power if
they don't think it can sell if it can
sell tickets to everywhere well see that
that was the what was weird is like I've
been
in the Amazon jungle I've been up the
amazon and we stayed in a little Hut and
the guy who
uh was like in charge of feeding us his
teenage son new Workaholics was a fan
I've been in Germany just like walking
along the [__] Berlin wall and people
are stopping me saying they love
Workaholics I'm like it was pretty
Global yeah like as far as a you know
kind of a cult comedy show goes I'm like
just it wasn't like it was it wasn't
like a hundred million dollar Marvel
movie yeah so I don't get it you know I
feel like they're really trying to
figure out what they're doing over there
at Paramount plus and they they have not
fully figured it out it's okay it's so
on it's so it feels so weird sometimes
how people who are making the choices
don't
don't have a real understanding of
what's going on or what they or what the
Zeitgeist of like people think is funny
is yeah well I think it was like
it it because Comedy Central hit and it
was people of a certain age right that
really loved it that they were like
just got out of college or was still in
high school or like maybe even a little
bit older than that that were like oh
yeah that was just like me when I was in
college or kids that were younger that
were like oh wow that seems crazy yeah
uh uh like when I got my first jobs I
hope me and my friends still live with
each other and party yeah boy party all
the time uh and then I think like
they're like people who had kids that
were the right age know about workhogs
because they're like oh my my teenage
Sons loved Workaholics and I think it
was just like the generation the kid the
guys that are in charge now didn't have
their kids were they don't know so they
didn't know [__] and I think it was just
we missed that window I think what a
[__]
that's all right things are going well
yeah things are going well yeah but it
is interesting to hear about that dude
the other night after a show this guy
this Mexican kid uh this guy at the show
he's a Mexican guy he comes up and he's
like this is the craziest request I ever
got he goes hey bro can you make a video
for my cousin Oscar and I was like yeah
man what do you want me to say and he's
like uh he got possessed by ghosts
that's what he said right yeah yeah he's
like oh he got possessed by ghost man so
just [__] telling something positive
so just try to um
exercises demons
yeah I was like uh Oscar Homie we miss
you homie
we miss you come back to the light I
didn't know what to say bro but that was
probably one of the craziest requests
that I've gotten from somebody so funny
um
oh dude in Germany one time we're biking
on the thing we're biking somewhere some
guy's in a park had a wiener on him I
mean a real [__] um
like a dots and you know what I'm saying
he had that [__] that thing would go
get the paper yeah the long long thick
yeah yeah he really had [__] I don't
know he did it but he somebody he did it
and uh he was swinging it like a rope in
the [__] part as you have to if you
got a thing like that you got to swing
it that's true huh yeah and it's also
Germany they don't even care that's just
an afternoon there right we were shocked
other people were literally splitting up
a uh you know maybe a little uh cutting
up a kiwi right next to it and having
like a little lunch yeah it's fine
that's just an afternoon for them yeah
just a German Afternoon brother
Deutsch
virus in Adam DeVine thank you brother
thanks Dale good to see you dude Gucci
man oh yeah
[Music]
gonna take